for me i'm his biggest cheerleader right
now but i also want to be out there
playing you know i also want to be
on the field and that's kind of why i'm
still doing it because i still enjoy
playing the game
um
so hopefully some of the lessons i'm
able to teach him are him watching me
play but if it's the other way around
you know i'm gonna do my best to help
him succeed
that's ryan fitzpatrick dolphins
quarterback from the what's next with
eric wood podcast fun fact eric wood
looks just like thurman merman from bad
santa that's completely irrelevant but
it entertains me every time i see eric
wood and realize he looks just like
thurman merman from bad santa all right
good santa in miami delivering tuatanga
viloa
look
ryan fitzpatrick's the veteran he played
well enough last year we talked last
segment about how they turned it around
after an 0-7 start and how good they
were down the stretch i mean i think
fitzpatrick is a guy who gets it he
knows his role at the same time he wants
to play and i think brian flores is
going to let him play if he shows he's
good enough to be the guy who deserves
to be on the field regardless of whether
or not tuatango viloa is on track
to start if fitzpatrick is better you go
with fitzpatrick i think flores is that
simple chris you're the one that knows
flores better than any of us don't don't
you think at the end of the day if it's
patrick is the best option
he's the guy who's going to play no
matter what investment they have in
tuatanga vailoa i i don't yeah i mean to
to what you're saying mike i don't think
they're going to be scared to play ryan
fitzpatrick no doubt about it i mean i
think if ryan fitzpatrick comes out of
training camp
and is clearly like the lead dog in the
clubhouse and wow he's outperformed to
every day and it's not even close
then yes brian flores he's gonna try to
put the best product out there and try
to win football games i do believe that
but
i do think if it's close and tua shows
let's say we have preseason games and he
shows some oh
some two of moments that they've all
been excited for i think you're gonna
have a hard time not starting them week
one i do you know we hear this every
year daniel jones is going to sit behind
elan manning carson wentz is going to
sit behind sam bradford and hey here's
the other thing to me with this
situation is you know this is different
than aaron rodgers and jordan love you
know aaron rodgers i think will truly
help jordan love jordan love's not a
threat to him right now or even really
next year
but
fitzpatrick yes he's the guy here he
wants to play he does this might be his
last year of playing as his true starter
in the nfl and i think he realizes that
so i don't think he's going to like open
up the hood completely for a guy that he
is legitimately going to compete against
here and just go hey here's all my
knowledge here's hey here's a trick so
the next time you run the play you can
look better than me running it no i
don't think that'll happen i think he'll
keep it close to the best with some
things because he wants to be the
starter and you got to worry about that
a little bit if you're in a miami
dolphins organization as well
brian flores is going to play the best
guy period and the question is this is
that this is the whole thing about
having a redshirt year for tuatangavaloa
was
a piece of tar
right from the start you know that
they're not drafting a guy
they are not drafting a guy
who is going to walk into training camp
with a limp and saying my hip hurts i
need the year off they're drafting a guy
who is ready to play opening day now
whether he wins the job does he have
enough time to win the job does he not
have enough time to win over the coaches
that is going to be the question to
tuatanga velo is going to be the
quarterback of this team soon i don't
know if it's going to be september 12th
i don't know if it's going to be october
18th but he will be the quarterback of
this team soon
and i'm sure that ryan fitzpatrick deep
down knows it
yeah and and look i think that
fitzpatrick part of his role of helping
get the most out of tuatanga vailoa is
to take this attitude that i'm going to
compete that i want to play because that
that keeps tuataga by lower from
slipping into this this notion that that
it's his job he's got to go win it i
remember when they put ryan tannehill at
the bottom of the depth chart in 2012.
it's like yeah what they're doing is
they are they are giving him the
opportunity
to climb the ladder internally and that
in so doing he builds confidence and he
puts himself in position where when it's
time to play he's going to feel better
about himself but i go back to last year
in miami when they brought in josh rosen
with the trade that they made with the
cardinals after the cardinals made colin
murray the first pick in the draft and
it's like well they're gonna surely
they're gonna go with rosen i mean he
was the tenth overall pick um you know
and then rosen's getting bro they're
going to groom rosen and they're going
to see what they have with rosen and
they eventually just decided we're going
with the better guy so i you know tua
will have every opportunity
and if he's the better guy he'll play
but uh fitz is going to try and fitz is
going to compete and if fitz happens to
be the better guy then i think that's
ultimately what the dolphins are going
to do even if it slows down the
development of tuatanga by low and i've
always been a guy who says
if you're going to invest a top 10 pick
on a quarterback you got to get him out
on the field you got to see what he can
do you got to let him develop because
all those lumps he takes now is going to
help him next year i mean that's the
downside isn't it chris to not starting
a rookie who may not be better than the
veteran right now he's losing those
opportunities to slow the game down so
he's better next year
yeah i mean i that's my thought you know
and again not that you're wrong by
sitting you know a year and learning
that way yeah i mean we saw patrick
mahomes he did that and came in and
threw 50 touchdown passes i mean so you
know you you you can't be wrong that way
but
i think at the end of the day you know
my thought and i think a more common
thought around the nfl is to what you're
saying mike get the guy in there let him
take his lumps let him learn the speed
of the game and how to play quarterback
in the nfl added to the fact too you
know tua didn't play the end of last
season in college football too so you
know then you sit out a whole nother
year that's that's a long time of not
playing football too that i would worry
about you know i'm i'm you know
i'm with you guys i think flores starts
ryan fitzpatrick if he thinks he gives
him the best chance to win but i think
if it gets close or it's real you know
real close through training camp or the
team starts to fall apart early in the
year they're going to pull the trigger
and go with tua he's the he's the fifth
pick of the draft you know he is the
future and there is no future with ryan
fitzpatrick who i know is not going to
die lately he's going to compete and i
respect him for that
good talk guys good talk i'll just keep
holding it down yeah it happens
every wednesday
happens every wednesday typically in the
second hour of the program i wait for
peter and uh peter and it's always uh
segment eight it's that's our magical
segment next weekend next week rather on
wednesday when we do this we have to be
on guard for segment eight for uh
peter to have an opportunity to talk
meet away oh wait talk
here's why
mike i got one for you
all right
i answer the phone she say curse word i
no no no no no no no no
that's good
let me ask you this guys who do you
think who do you think starts first tua
or justin herbert with the chargers if
you had to pick tua or herbert who do
you think's the first guy to see the
field
do it uh
no question about it yeah
all right let's take a break yeah i
agree i don't know if justin herbert
starts at all this year
might not
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports